so far we are in the middle range of
their projections for infections
and at the lower end of their
projections for mortality
and we also know that if we were now to
delay
this fourth step for instance to
september or later
then we would be reopening as the
weather gets colder
and as the virus acquires a greater
natural advantage and when
schools are back and so
we think now is the right moment to
proceed when we have
the natural fire break of the school
holidays in the next few days
and chris and patrick will set out uh in
just a minute
how we are meeting the four tests for
step four
in england but it is absolutely vital
that we proceed now with caution
and i cannot say this powerfully or
emphatically
enough this pandemic
is not over this disease
coronavirus continues to carry risks for
you
and your family we cannot simply revert
instantly from monday the 19th of july
to life as it was before covid
we will stick to our plan to lift legal
restrictions
and to lift social distancing but
we expect and recommend that people wear
a face covering
in crowded and enclosed spaces where you
come into contact with those you don't
normally meet
such as on public transport we're
removing the government instruction to
work from home where you can
but we don't expect that the whole
country will return
to their desks as one from monday
and we're setting out guidance for
business for a gradual return to work
over the summer and as a matter of
social responsibility
we're urging nightclubs and other venues
with large crowds to make use of the nhs
covid pass
which shows proof of vaccination
vaccination
a recent negative test or natural
immunity
as a means of entry
we're updating our guidance for the
clinically extremely vulnerable
on how they can keep themselves safe and
i generally urge
everyone to keep thinking of others
and to consider the risks we'll keep our
tough
border policy including quarantine for
those arriving
from redless countries and we will keep
the test
trace and isolate system in place
every week that goes by we're getting
hundreds of thousands more jabs
into arms and our delay to the roadmap
that we announced last month has enabled
us to get seven
million more jabs in the last four weeks
alone
by next monday two-thirds of adults will
have received
a second dose and every adult will have
been offered
a first days and it is the single
most crucial thing now that you get that
jab a jab that could protect you
and your family and allow you for
instance to go on holiday
and this is of course only thanks to the
vaccine program
that we are able to take these cautious
steps
now but to take these steps
we must be cautious and we must be
vaccinated
so please get that jab thanks very much
i'm now going to pass to
chris to do the slides thank you prime
minister first slide please
uh as people will recall there were four
roadmap
tests and i'm going to go through each
of them in turn
the first of them was that the vaccine
deployment program continues
successfully
and i think people are very aware of the
fact that this is going very well the
nhs has ruled this out
in a magnificent way supported by
volunteers
and people have come to come in very
large numbers uh with the majority of
every age group
in adulthood now having had their first
vaccination and the great great majority
of the older age groups having both
first and second vaccinations
next slide please the second test was
that evidence shows the vaccines
are sufficiently effective in reducing
hospitalizations
and deaths in those vaccinated and
we've got real live data from the uk
um which actually shows for the delta
variant which is the one which is
currently dominant
we have considerable confidence that one
dose reduces by a reasonable margin
roughly a third the chance of getting
a symptomatic infection but two doses
reduce that very substantially further
to somewhere between 78 and 80 percent
reduction these are estimates and next
slide please
if we move on to people having uh
hospitalization and deaths
these vaccines are substantially more
effective than they are
even against symptomatic disease so one
dose
a 6 9 to 88 reduction and
two doses over 90 reduction in the
chance of hospitalization
not 100 but these are very highly
effective
vaccines next slide please
when it comes to the third test
infection rates do not risk
a risk do not risk a surge in
hospitalizations we should put
unsustainable pressure on the nhs
inevitably
we have to be more cautious in our
interpretation of the data
at this point in time as you can see
from this slide
the rates of hospitalizations whilst not
trivial
and rising so over 2 700 people
are in hospital with kovid at the moment
is way below
both the uh the first bit and the second
bit of the peak so autumn
and spring of this year went to this
year
and spring of last year however next
slide please
if we look at the the cases admissions
and deaths over time we have to be
aware of the fact that the way epidemics
work is they double
now in the case of cases the autumn wave
which is in
orange here and the current wave are
going at very similar rates to what they
did
to the autumn wave last year
if we then look at admissions and these
are not on exactly the same scale just a
point a technical point
but what you can see is that whilst the
the cases are following almost an
identical track to the previous wave
uh the admissions are going
significantly below that
but they are still rising at a slower
exponential rate and then the third uh
thing is the the mortality rate death
rate uh
fortunately at this point in time much
lower than it was previously
but again this is rising so with all of
these
the key question is at what point do the
does the epidemic curve uh come to an
end
and turn over and the rates start to go
down and
there cannot be certainty about this so
therefore we have inevitably
we cannot be quite as confident on this
uh test as the others but at this point
modelling data and other data would
imply that if we go slowly with the next
stage of the roadmap the expectation is
this will not reach the
point where it is putting unsustainable
pressure on the nhs but to repeat the
prime minister's points there is an
expectation unfortunately that
the number of cases cases going to
hospital will go up and the number of
deaths
will go up in the current wave
next slide please the final test
is that our assessment is that the risks
are not fundamentally changed
by a new variant of concern and the
delta
variant is now the dominant variant in
the uk so this is now the normal variant
in the uk so that's not a variant
concern anymore
which it was when we first talked about
it in one of these press conferences
looking at the other uh variants of
concern
uh in the uk the numbers are low and
are not rising and in fact in several
cases are in fact
shrinking at this point in time so we do
not think at this point that there is
any reason to think any
uh current variants of concern are going
to change the analysis that's been made
so therefore three tests passed i think
fairly clearly
one test with the caution that i put in
in terms of the data
i just uh before i finish wanted to um
just summarize
where i think some of the science
scientific and medical opinion is
uh to in a sense uh in in support of
what the prime minister has just said
there are three areas where there is
really very
overwhelming uh wide agreement between
scientific and medical opinion
and there's one area where uh decision
where opinions are more mixed
there is very wide agreement and was
very wide agreement
that the four-week delay that we have
just had to the roadmap
was going to have a significant impact
on reducing
the amount of hospitalizations and
deaths and
that that opinion has not changed so
very strong view that that particular
period of delay
was an extremely important thing to do
to reduce deaths to reduce cases and
reduce pressure
on the nhs secondly there is
extremely wide agreement that whenever
we go through the next
step there is going to be what's called
an exit wave there will be a wave
associated with that
and that the slower we take it the fewer
the people
will have coveted the smaller the peak
will be
and the smaller the number of people who
go into hospital and die
so going very slowly through this step
is really essential and this again is an
overwhelming view
of the scientific uh people who've
looked at this
and of the medical profession there was
a
letter on this by the all the royal
colleges of
medicine for example over the weekend uh
and so this is an overwhelming view we
should go slowly and steadily and
cautiously as the prime minister
has laid out there is less agreement
about what is an ideal date
to make a move and the other reason for
that is there is no such thing as an
ideal date
all the possible dates have downsides
and as the prime minister has said
uh if we go this point in time uh we go
at a point when there are still some
people being vaccinated but
we are not going at a point when uh
schools are just coming back
and we're not going to point where we're
going into autumn and winter and the
modeling uh
studies have been done on this largely
show that
all dates essentially tend to lead to
broadly similar
outcomes different models come to very
slightly different conclusions
but there is no clear evidence in
comparison to the previous
occasion when a delay was clearly going
to make a difference there is no clear
evidence that a delay now
is going to make a difference what is
going to make a difference is going
slowly
and the final thing again to reiterate
that what the prime minister said where
there is overwhelming
agreement is that vaccination reduces
the chances
that you will catch covid that anybody
who's vaccinated
will have severe covid or go into
hospital and it also reduces the chances
that they will pass on covid so it both
protects themselves
it protects all of us and it protects
other people as well so the evidence on
vaccinations is overwhelming thank you
very much
thanks very much chris uh patrick
anything to our before we go to the
public
let's go to questions from the public
michael from manchester
as coverage restrictions are lifted and
social interactions return
what criteria will be used to determine
if any restrictions
should return in future for example if
death rates rose
to a certain level or cases in hospitals
or waiting lists screwed
in a certain area thank you well
michael thank you very much i can give
you a a straightforward answer
uh on that from uh the policy
perspective we will keep all the data
under constant review
uh throughout the the rest of this year
um probably i'm afraid into
to next year as well and if we are
seeing
uh very exceptional circumstances uh
that
that you describe or the arrival of some
uh new
variant that we haven't bargained for
budgeted for
uh that really is causing us a real
problem then obviously
we must uh we must rule nothing out and
i've been very very clear uh about that
we we must
protect the public and we will we will
we will not hesitate to use
uh the means that we have at our
disposal
but the way things are working at the
moment
we do think that if we are cautious
and we go slowly as chris has said
uh that we can continue uh with the the
road map as it
as it stands that is that is that is our
hope but i
i wonder whether any chris or patrick
want to
want to add to that i think that's right
prime minister um the important thing is
that we monitor this very carefully all
of the parameters you've talked about
hospitalizations
deaths and cases and
be aware that of course because
epidemics double
you have to make the decision before you
get to the stage that um
the the things things look really bad
and so it's important to monitor this in
real time keep an eye on it and make
sure that if things go in the wrong
direction
decisions are made early enough thanks
very much
uh sarah from brighton we know that two
doses of the vaccine are very effective
at reducing severe cases of covid19
but what is the evidence that the
vaccine also prevents you from
unknowingly passing the virus on
and how does the vaccine remove the need
for self-isolation
does having two doses of the vaccine
mean you're less likely to infect others
sarah very good question i have a figure
in my head of reduction of transmission
of about
67 or something like that but uh crystal
patrick do you want to
go and then chris may want to we'll come
in on this i mean
we haven't got absolute figures for
delta so it's important to recognize
that there's uncertainty around
the numbers on this but if you took um
out figures alpha and if you took a sort
of general approach to this from the
data we've got
roughly speaking the vaccinations are
decreasing the chance of somebody
vaccinated from
catching the virus by let's say 50 or so
maybe a little higher after double
vaccination depending
roughly it looks like they're decreasing
the risk of transmission
if you have caught the virus to somebody
else by about 50 percent
so overall that means as a vaccinated
person
you're something like 70 75
less less likely to be able to infect
somebody else
in any situation because you you're less
likely to catch it and you're less
likely to pass it on
and those figures will change as we get
more data but chris you may want to add
no i completely agree with those numbers
and i think uh just the thing to point
out is that of course that means that
roughly a quarter of people can still
part it on and therefore
it's not a you someone being vaccinated
substantially reduces the risk for
people around them
but does not eliminate them at that risk
which is the reason why
isolation is still important if someone
has coveted or has a high chance of
having covered
and just to be clear those figures are
about likelihood of contracting the
virus
as chris said earlier on the protection
of vaccines against severe disease
hospitalizations and deaths are very
much higher
and indeed after two vaccination doses
are right up in the sort of 90 plus
percent
thank you hugh pim bbc
thank you prime minister given the
pressure on hospitals
will you end the requirement of nhs
staff
who've come into contact with a positive
case to self-isolate even if they've
been double jabbed and if so when
will you bring forward the change for
the general public if they've been
double jab they don't need to
self-isolate bring it forward from the
middle of august
and a question for sir patrick valance
and chris witty
can you spell out some of the risks
involved with opening up
on july the 19th in england for example
to the nhs
yeah a very very good question hugh
about the
uh the restrictions on the the nhs
caused by the
the current measures we will be looking
at ways of
of trying to get the nhs back to
operating uh in in a in a pre-covered
way without the the need for
for social distancing and for uh for
isolation
uh contact isolation but uh
you'll just have to wait a little bit uh
for the for the health secretary to be
setting out
exactly how we uh we want to do that
plainly as
as we uh reduce uh
the times people have to wait for their
care we're gonna want to to get back to
the nhs
operating as much as possible
as it was before but that will be
happening uh in the next
few weeks we hope uh patrick
well there's no doubt that we are in um
a third wave
infection infections are rising rapidly
and i expect them to continue to rise
and the more mixing we have the more
infection
is going to spread so there's no doubt
that step four will bring
increases in spread of infection
and although the relationship between
infections and hospitalization is
different
it still exists so the risk of
hospitalization
is something like four-fold lower than
it was
and the risk of death is nine or ten
times lower than it was but it still
exists
so the models which have been released
today
clearly show an expectation that
infections will continue to rise
if behavior returns immediately to
pre-pandemic levels that would be a very
very big rise if we go
slowly and cautiously that will be less
of a rise
but we can't escape the fact that any
increase like that will be associated
with an increase in hospitalizations
and sadly with deaths as well and that i
think is the expectation
that that we should have over this next
period as we go into
a phase of opening up and we're already
seeing the effects of increased mixing
with the wave as it stands already
could i just add two things to that one
just on just to make the point that that
would be true irrespective of what the
date was that this happened this
this exit wave is going to happen uh
whenever a release happens and
but what will mitigate it is going
slowly and on the first one on the nhs
staff
side this has been discussed by
senior clinicians including the the for
uk cmo chief medical officers
and what you're trying to do is balance
two different things
doctors nurses other medical uh and
social care staff
are dealing with more vulnerable people
so the risks of them having the disease
and passing it on are greater
but if there's too few staff in a
hospital or in a ward or a nursing home
that is also potentially a danger to
patients and so what you're trying to do
is balance two risks against one another
uh and achieve that in the best way
possible and uh that's very much uh
something which as you know is something
is a key part of medicine it's just a
matter of balancing risks
thanks hugh carl did an itv news
thank you prime minister uh prime
minister you used to say that
these steps uh on the roadmap would be
irreversible
do you still believe that and can i ask
chris whitty about his tests and
specifically test number
three uh that you talked us through
um do you have an idea of
what level of daily admissions would be
unsustainable
for the nhs because spy m has said today
that once you got halfway to that point
you would have to
take action and implement contingency
plans so
what level of hospital admissions would
be unsustainable
and how close do you think we might get
to that level
carl thanks yes of course i hope that
the road map is
irreversible that's the we've always
said we hope that it will be
irreversible but in order to have a an
irreversible roadmap we've also said
it's got to be
a cautious approach that's why we we
waited
uh those those extra weeks to get seven
million more jabs into
into people's arms uh that was why we
took the that step in
in june on june the the 14th uh and
why what we're saying now is you know
people have got to
we will we will proceed on on on monday
the 19th but we want people to
remember that this thing is this
pandemic is not
over we must proceed in a cautious
way and if we are cautious and we get
vaccinated if everybody takes the
opportunity
uh that that they have to get vaccinated
then yes we can we can make progress
steadily and that's what we
we want to achieve on the question you
asked me when there isn't a single
number where
below it things are fine and above it
there's a big problem
things go up in kind of stages you start
off with
pressure on the general system then you
get to a point where there may be a need
to
uh reduce elective care and there's a
long waiting list so we want to try and
avoid that if possible
and then you get into things where
you're reducing urgent care and then you
start putting pressure on the
wider emergency services so there isn't
a kind of cut-off point
we what we would hope is that the uh the
peak that we will see
if people go very quietly carefully if
we all go very carefully
uh over the next period will be
significantly lower
than the peak we saw in january for
example
which put huge pressure on the nhs but i
think to think that we're not going to
have any pressure on the nhs is
not fully realistic and the other thing
which is different this time around
is previously we've done a an
intervention which has led to the whole
country having a peak at roughly the
same time
that may not be the case here so we may
have a situation where certain
certain bits of the pres of the nhs are
under pressure
and then that goes down but other bits
it goes up so there may be
pressure at different times around the
country thanks ben kentish lbc
thank you prime minister um you've
talked today about um people
needing to wear masks expecting people
to wear masks but our country doesn't
run on expectations it runs on
rules now when we have rules in all
areas of public life designed to protect
ensure people act in a way to protect
others from speeding and drink driving
to facing fines of thousands of pounds
even for dropping litter in the street
why in the middle of a global pandemic
do you think that wearing a mask
covering your face and mouth
should be one of the few areas of public
life where people are expected to behave
in a certain way
rather than told to do so if i could
just ask sir patrick
what does the science say about the rate
of herd immunity when the uk is likely
to reach
some degree of herd immunity and
therefore when we should see cases
start to come down after the peak and
just finally to chris witty
given we've heard figures today about
the nhs backlog but
possibly hitting 13 million how
concerned are you in that context about
the
probability of cases rising prevalence
rising as high as you've outlined is
likely to be
thanks very much uh ben on
the issue of masks we're really
following the same
principle that we're following with all
the the legislation that we've
uh we've had in place we're trying to
move towards
uh personal responsibility people uh
thinking about
others as well as about themselves and
that applies to uh the social distancing
applies to
how we think about the vulnerable uh how
we make sure that we continue to
exercise extreme
caution as we continue with uh
the fight against a very dangerous
disease and clearly with
uh with masks uh there is a
there's a world of difference as i said
last week uh between
sitting alone on a an empty uh station
platform
or in a crowded tube tube train and
on a crowded tube train we would as a
government expect and
recommend that people wear masters and
i've no doubt that that is what
uh what people will do in terms of
immunity
uh we've now got high levels of
antibodies
across the country um and uh by july the
19th
two two-thirds of peop adults should be
a double vaccinated and every
adult offered a single vaccine so we're
getting
to really quite decent levels of
antibody and it's worth
thinking of it not in terms of an
absolute cut off but actually there's a
continuum
and the more immunity there is across
the population the harder it is for the
virus to spread
and certainly the more difficult it is
for the virus to cause severe disease
and hospitalization so
every bit of build up of that becomes
beneficial
and whether you reach a stage when you
get to true herd immunity i think is a
different
different issue and it depends on things
like the virus
reproductive rate whether it's
distributed across all of the population
the immunity whether they're pockets
that have
lower vaccination rates and so on so
it's really important that we get to
everybody and get to particularly the
young people who are now coming forward
brilliantly for their vaccination
make sure they come forward really to
get the vaccine that's offered come back
for the second dose
and we are on track to have significant
levels of immunity that will really
impede the ability of this virus to
transmit and cause damage
and that will bring the
possibility of future big waves would go
at that point i mean you may
get it if there's a vaccine escape but
we'll be in a much much better position
so this reaching high levels of immunity
is critically important
i mean the nhs has been doing a
remarkable job in trying to reduce the
waiting lists that have been
built up over the time that kovid's been
putting pressure on the nhs which is
obviously now
uh since march of uh last year uh but
um there is both uh inevitably some uh
quite significant degree of overhang
from that period
and at the moment uh there is some
pressure from mckovid and that is likely
to go up over the next period
so inevitably everybody who works in the
nhs and indeed everybody who might use
it or has friends or relatives who might
use it
is going to want to keep the numbers of
cases right down and that is one of the
many reasons why
we really want to urge people to take
this really steadily because that's the
way we keep the numbers down
keep the pressure on the nhs lower and
make the possibility of clearing
this this this number of cases uh much
easier
thank you chris smith the times
thank you chief medical officer you said
that going slowly
is essential so can you all be clear
about exactly what you want us to do
or not to do as of next week should we
change our current habits at all
carry on sticking to current levels or
social contacts
should people not go to some of the
nightclubs and other venues that are
opening next week and
should people avoid parties to celebrate
the end of restrictions kind of detail
the prime minister picking up on your
answer to michael are you making a
direct link
between people's behavior and the risk
of restrictions returning
and if you do need your act what would
be the first thing you'd be reaching for
well uh i'll i'll have a go that chris
first
the i think what we want to to do is
get people to uh think carefully about
the ending of the restrictions that were
were announcing today and to make sure
on the immortal words of
of jvt uh jonathan van tan they don't
they don't rip the pants out of it or
tear the pants out of it i think is what
he
uh what he said ages ago and
i think i said last week don't be demob
happy
about this this is not the end of covid
it requires constant vigilance it means
thinking about others as well as
yourself it means
thinking about uh we're wearing a face
covering in confined spaces where you
meet other people
that you don't normally meet as as i've
said
as we said earlier on we said last week
it means
uh continuing to think about the risk of
uh transmission to the the the shielded
the
uh the extremely vulnerable uh how you
behave uh with them in their presence
obviously exercising common sense
because
the the the legal restrictions have come
off
should not be taken as an invitation by
everybody
uh simply to have a great uh jubilee and
uh
freedom from uh from any kind of caution
or restraint that's what we're saying i
think um
what the scientists are saying is this
is
the right date or is as good as any
other date
to do this but it's got to be taken
seriously and we've got to go as slowly
as we
as we can given the uh the constraints
we're under and
i think that for me that makes that
makes a great deal of sense
if we held off till september
if we waited uh to go for the
the legal unlockings that we are uh then
we'd be doing it as i said in a context
of a great deal
uh more risk from the from the weather
plus we wouldn't have
the advantage of the school holidays and
so on this is
about as good a time as any but to do it
properly and sensibly
everybody has got to be cautious i i
think don't think that
the things which are going to make a
difference will come as any surprise
to any anybody in the uk uh over the
next uh period
the things that we've all been doing for
a long time you'll be incredibly good
incredibly patient to doing it the
hands-faced space thing
wash your hands cover your face in
crowded uh areas
avoid crowded areas where you can avoid
unnecessary meetings but
be sensible on it and above all the
thing which is new
uh get yourself vaccinated it protects
yourself it protects your family it
protects everyone around you
these are the things that people have
done very steadily and as the prime
minister has said
the fact that we can move from uh
working at home
doesn't mean that we should rush it
everything should be done
steadily and it's really a it's a
message about going steadily
and that's what people have done all the
way through this they've been incredibly
good at it
uh actually all the way through every
you know across across the country
uh and all four nations uh and uh that's
all we're really saying is carry on
being steady
can i just add to two to that one is the
absolute necessity to continue
self-isolating if you test positive
very important to stop spread and um
and if you're symptomatic get a test and
in reopening make sure that ventilation
get to get to priority
so summer is quite a good time to do
that to obviously make sure windows are
open
and there's sufficient ventilation in
buildings
thanks chris dan bloom the mirror
hello prime minister um well there's a
lot of absurdity of uncertainty of
course
um we understand that the modeling for
the government is pointing to
roughly 100 to 200 deaths per day at the
peak of the third wave
um is this a price that you're willing
to pay for freedom
uh or is that sort of range inevitable
now whenever we unlock
and to the scientists uh under what
circumstances do you
believe that restrictions would need to
come back this autumn or winter and
how likely do you think that is to
happen prime minister third one very
quickly for may
you condemn the vile racism aimed at
england players overnight so does that
mean you would now take the knee as they
have thank you
thanks very much dan on the um
the timing of the of the third wave and
and where we are
i think it was chris put it very very
well uh which
was that there isn't a an optimal
time um but i think that
the reality is that both uh
deaths and hospitalizations uh are sadly
going to to
rise whenever uh you go for an
an unlocking of the kind that we are and
uh we we simply must
we as as chris puts it there will be an
exit
wave and we simply have to to recognize
that
and uh as i on the on
the on black lives matter and uh the
importance of that i simply repeat what
i've said
many many times i think people should
feel free to show their respect and show
uh how much they condemn uh racism uh in
this country
in any way that they choose and uh i i
thought it was
i was there last night and uh
i thought i noted that the whole crowd
was respectful uh when our players took
the knee and and they did they
they did not uh i didn't hear a single
boom myself
i mean in terms of i mean you know we
have said from quite a
time ago that there's likely to be an
increase in both
covid and other respiratory infections
over winter and i don't think that
is a terribly controversial statement
that happens every winter but we've now
got covered on top
and for a variety of reasons we might
have a slightly more difficult
winter for flu and a variety of other
respiratory infections
that's very different and you know
that's and that would probably lead to
people taking sensible precautions as
they are at the moment
and has as they have done for a while
that's very different from issues around
restrictions which are very much an
issue for ministers uh but
uh that you know there is not an
inevitability in any way
that because we have a surge which may
need may need to be lead to people
uh thinking okay we need to be a bit
more careful that leads to
anything which ministers have to do
that's just a reality that
we're going to face in the coming winter
and may well face in future winters
thanks very much dan esto weber politico
um given everything you said today about
moving
slowly and steadily
how does el square with the previous
references
to reopening as freedom day
or big bang and this being
irreversible do you think there's
a danger of mixed messages and would you
like to take
this opportunity to clarify to people
that they need to
hang on to their masks
and then secondly uh particularly
for the prime minister he said at the
beginning
that we are still hoping to
go ahead with the world cup bit and i
just wondered how can you expect that
to go ahead after the scenes of disorder
in wembley yesterday
esther thank you very much first of all
i
on the on this step i think it's crucial
for everybody to understand
that yes this is a big package of
of measures that we're announcing but it
will only
work as a as a fourth step if
people are cautious in the way that they
uh go ahead with it and that's why
i've said all the things that uh i've
said this
this afternoon about how to do it and i
i just underline
everything that chris and chris and
patrick have have said
in order for this to be irreversible
it's got to be cautious
but the most important thing is for
everybody
who gets an offer of a vaccine to take
it up
we've done outstandingly well in this
country we have a higher rate of
vaccination
than virtually any other country in the
world now
and that's greatly uh it's a great
achievement
but we still have a lot of people
particularly younger people who have the
chance to take it up
and i really hope that they uh they do
the next few days and esther
on your point about um the the
world cup bid um well this is a long and
difficult process and i was i'm a
veteran of the 2010
scenes in zurich which you probably
forgot about where we tried to get it
uh last time and uh which didn't go
uh very well but i i obviously i think
that the
the uk does have a a very good case
together with
uh together with ireland and uh we will
be
we will be making that case i think it
was
a shame that a small minority
yesterday uh tried to spoil it or
behave badly i don't think that they
they damage the atmosphere certainly not
in the in the stadium
itself uh but we will be we will be
looking at
uh exactly what happened i think there
were particular difficulties in
uh policing and enforcing an event in
the context of
uh of the testing and the social
distancing
rules but uh irrespective of uh
of that i i do think that the uk has
a very very uh and working together with
uh with ireland has a uh a very good
case and
uh you know i wouldn't want to let my
hopes run away with me because i
as i say i remember what it was like 10
years ago
but we will certainly give it our best
shot
okay everybody thank you very much thank
you
there we are that's the prime minister
ending on the football
and he began also talking about the
football he said gareth southgate's
side had made history and they brought
joy
to many and to those who racially abused
certain players on social media he said
this
shame on you and i hope you crawl back
under the rock you came from and then
the prime minister moved on
to covid and he confirmed that the legal
restrictions will end
next monday but he said uh
there were some very was some very
strong advice that
the government would be handing out
venues were strongly advised to insist
on masks in crowded indoor areas
also on public transport
don't be dmob happy he repeated that
phrase and also
quoted jonathan van tam don't rip the
pants out of it
and then scientists showed some charts
showing that the wave this wave of cases
um was rising like
cases last autumn but hospital
admissions were less
and deaths were much less and he said
though cases will rise
after the restrictions are listed lifted
we should not reach the point where
uh the nhs would not be able to
cope uh political editor beth rigby
is uh with me so beth i mean what struck
me
was that recently he had said that uh
you know restrictions were going to be
lifted freedom day
beckoned this time it is still happening
but with
much more it seemed to me caution and
caveats and so forth
oh yeah there's certainly been a change
in emphasis
from the prime minister there backed up
by his scientific
advisers it is true last week at the
press conference when i asked him about
the irreversibility
he said i don't want people uh to be
dmob happy but
he was definitely doubling down on that
message
today it was all about going slowly it
was all about
caution it was all about warning uh that
some of these measures might have to be
reversed if we don't all
uh do our bit and follow the advice but
he's not making things that might be
mandatory you might expect to be
mandatory such as face masks
he's decided not to make that compulsory
legally but rather ask people to take
personal responsibility what struck me
in that press conference was
what professor whitty said about the nhs
because you remember the government had
four tests as to whether it could
proceed with the roadmap one of them
uh was that the nhs would not be
overwhelmed and chris whittie there
wasn't completely convinced about that
he said
um that they that he uh thought
that it could be overwhelmed he said his
expectation so i'm just finding the
quote
he said he was not as confident that the
test on no risk of the nhs being
overwhelmed
was being met as hospitalizations rose
he also said his expectation or the
expectation
was that the nhs won't be overwhelmed if
we go
back to normal slowly and that's what
chris whittie kept stressing there
there has also been papers coming out as
that press conference went on
so much the sage modeling uh presid
predicts
in this third wave which they expect to
peak
in august one to two thousand one
thousand to two thousand
hospitalizations a day
one hundred to two hundred deaths a day
so
you can see why chris wooty is anxious
about what happens to the nhs and it
partly depends on people's
behavior and what they do when these
restrictions these legal restrictions
are lifted
just in the language as well we were
talking beforehand about this idea
of irreversible and
he was asked specifically about that and
i think he answered i hope that it is
irreversible and the other sort of
language thing i noticed was um they
were saying
people use their personal judgment now
they seem to be saying
people must use their social
responsibility
yeah this is what uh we were talking
about in terms of
weakening some of the language around
irreversibility but strengthening the
language around trying to mandate
people to behave in a certain way when
it comes to
irreversibility on february the 21st
when he announced the road map he said
the prime minister said we are embarking
on a cautious but irreversible approach
today he said i hope that the road map's
irreversible we've always said that we
hope
that the road map will be irreversible
and then he said that depended on the
level of caution
by which people drove out if you like of
this final phase
of unlocking so there is a shift in
language
but then as you noted a big
strengthening
of language around uh what he expected
people to do
so he said last week he suggested that
people might want to wear
a face mask in a crowded space today he
said it was his expectation
and recommendation that they did so
strengthening the language because
they've clearly looked at the modeling
we've had papers out
from sage from the scientific advisors
from july
the seventh looking at the modeling
looking at the surge looking at the rise
in hospitalizations
and now the prime minister just pressing
the break down a bit
and saying actually please do wear a
face mark in fact
i would like you to that i'm strongly
recommending it uh
please businesses do get people to use
their covered passes
and and uh corporations can you just not
bring back
uh everyone to work at once so they're
trying to find
ways to reduce transmission as we
approach
this big opening up moment which will
still happen uh we're told okay beth
thank you very much
indeed and boris johnson was speaking at
the end there about events at
wembley uh last night when
a small minority of fans
stormed the turnstiles and
got into the ground without tickets and
the fa has issued a statement saying
that security and stewarding numbers
uh for the final exceeded the
requirements for the match and were
greater than
any previous event at wembley stadium
however the behavior of the people who
illegally forced their way
into the stadium was unacceptable
dangerous and showed a total disregard
for the safety
and security protocols in place no
steward or security staff should be
subjected to this type of behavior and
we thank them for their support we also
apologize to anyone at the match whose
experience was affected by
what the fa then call an unprecedented
level of public
disorder and it ends we'll continue to
work with the relevant authorities to
identify and take action against those
people
where possible that's a statement from
the fa
and 19 police officers were injured
last night and there were 86 arrests
they've been made so far including 53 at
wembley alone
the metropolitan police say their
operation went according to plan
we had a considerable resource outside
we did not lose control at any point
clearly
there was behavior from some individuals
that was unacceptable
how wembley managed the fans inside the
venue
is for wembley and policing is for
outside but
it's a really important relationship and
we work very closely with them on the
night
for unprecedented scenes that were
challenging but we dealt with
quickly and effectively
so lockdown will be lifted in england
next monday
let's just remind ourselves of the
changes which will take effect
a week today the legal requirement to
wear masks in shops and on public
transport will be dropped though people
will be encouraged to wear them in
crowded public spaces
uh there'll also be no more restrictions
on socializing dropping the rule of six
indoors close contact venues like
nightclubs will be able to reopen
and the same goes for mass gatherings
and large events
with no limits uh whatsoever on capacity
at sports events well joining me is
linda bold
professor of public health at the
university of
edinburgh thanks for being with us once
again so
are you comfortable with warnings to be
cautious replacing firm
clearly laid out rules that legal
restrictions
not really to be perfectly frank mark i
mean i think that the
as beth was saying there's been a shift
in messaging it's nuanced it's now
firmer than it was before
i guess the question i would ask is what
proportion of the
uk population we're listening or the
english population in particular we're
listening
to that briefing and will have picked up
on these shifts in tone
we know from lots of other public health
policies that a voluntary approach and
doesn't mean that everybody's going to
follow it and i think people will be
delighted of course that
many other things are opening including
much more